[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so much for being here um i
needed to put heels on because as you
can see i'm covered with this podium
everything in europe is taller than me
so
i want you to think of
some tutorial
or technical guide
or some documentation
or any
any really any learning of resource you
have used as part of your career
think about it for a moment and really
try to find what those pieces are what
sticks out in your mind what's the first
thing that comes to mind what's
something that you remember fondly
now think of the best learning resources
you have ever used think about what was
common among them think about those that
you would have no problem sharing with
other people
or saying hey if you want to learn this
this is absolutely the best thing to use
to learn it
and then think of the absolute worst
pieces of learning resources you have
ever used
i'm willing to bet you that everything
that you have categorized as the worst
learning resources has had some missing
pieces
and that's what i'm here to talk to you
about today
it's not only just documentation it just
kind of fit and it's kind of a cool
quick name but this really really
applies to any type of learning resource
that you may create
as a technical person so a developer a
front end engineer
anybody that writes any type of
technical documentation and we all
should fit that profile because we
should at least be doing it for
ourselves
so we'll start with the bad things that
we are absolutely used to
what does it mean
whenever we see bad learning resources
this is usually what we look like i
don't understand what does it mean
most bad learning resources are either
unclear
or unusable
and why they're unclear and unusable i
will tell you exactly why they fall
under one of these categories that i
know even i have done so myself
of why these learning resources are bad
how we can be aware of them and how we
can fix them so we'll start with smh idk
or shaking my head i don't know
so
when you are learning something new or
when you look up some new learning
resource some documentation and you find
a random phrase here right something
like to create a ttl index on this field
use the following command
so
as developers maybe this is common to us
maybe we know what ttl stands for but if
you are in photography maybe this is a
different type of acronym if you are in
a different field maybe ttl means
something different
or the cri is an api for container
runtimes to integrate with cubelet on a
node what
i mean i know we've all been tech before
and i know that tech moves fast but
sometimes even we ourselves need
reminders of what these acronyms mean
and what we're learning about in what
context
or again whether you're using the mern
the mean the meven stack tutorial this
will be
useful to learn the fundamentals
so as you can probably tell everything
here that has been using acronyms it's
not that it's bad to use acronyms it's
the fact that sometimes you don't know
what they mean the first time that you
see it so just spell it out ttl means
time to live as in time to live index
cri api means container runtime
interface for that particular context or
application programming interface even
something like api that we take for
granted think of people who are
switching careers think of people who
are just starting out these are things
that may be so familiar to us and
something that we're like everybody
knows what this means no not everyone
will know what that means so at least
spell it out for the first time
and then finally mirn mean meven spell
it out who knows maybe somebody is
thinking of a completely different stack
for one of those letters be explicit
about it
for this just say the damn thing please
[Applause]
so let's shake my head i have no idea
next thing step skipper and this is
where sound comes in so i'm pretty sure
you have all done some sort of tutorial
like this
all right guys welcome to my beginner's
programming tutorial we're going to
create a simple program all right first
we're going to type in public class
program then public static void
mainstream arts you know how it goes
then import in this old ass outdated
library from like 1994. oh yeah by the
way i'm using java 7. not java 8 so
sorry if you have to start over all
right and then i'm going to copy and
paste this giant chunk of code uh what
this does is like uh it makes your
computer do stuff um put that in your
program and then compile and execute it
and there we go we've created minecraft
right
[Applause]
frustrating is it to go through a
tutorial like that it's always like that
it's create this thing it's add this
code and tada you should be up and
running now no we need to make sure that
we are super explicit about our steps
yes
this one this one this one okay
all right hello hello hello
okay so
all right so what we want to do is we
need to be way more explicit with the
steps that we have we can't leave any of
those gaps out
really when the steps that we write look
like this what they really should look
like are something like this create that
thing oh and by the way set this setting
if it's not on by default
also add this code then replace the
placeholders that are in my sample code
and make sure they have your own values
don't forget to hit the deploy button
these things seem so simple but if you
are following something through for the
first time or even if you're a seasoned
developer and this is something
completely new to you you want all of
those explicit details every machine is
different every context is different
everyone's background is different so
the more explicit you are about your
steps the more likely you'll actually
get to that number three the ta-da you
should be up and running now the more
you'll be able to get to that developer
delay where someone will reach the end
have something working and actually have
some useful uh tutorial to be using and
even more explicit add things like pro
tips you know be sure to delete this if
this is just something that you're
trying out for the first time if it's
going to cost them something tell them
to delete it because a lot of us i know
we play around with something for a
little bit we forget it and then we have
like a 30 000 aws bill nobody wants that
so tell them tell them everything there
is to know use that expertise that you
have use the mistakes that you have
learned from and add them to all of the
pieces of information or tutorials that
you create so it can be way more
valuable for others
it's in the details
all
all of those details
so don't be a step skipper
next
i'm going to have some enemies with this
one
i always have enemies with this one but
i say foo your fubar
what does that mean
[Applause]
so when you look at this piece of code
you've probably never seen it before
and if i asked you to tell me what
exactly it's doing how long would it
take you to figure it out
exactly thank you
because we have you know single letter
variables we have random names that
don't mean anything we have damn foo and
damn bar we don't want these things
anymore instead be explicit
this is actually a
potential solution that i wrote for one
of the advent of code problems so one of
the problems you had to do was find the
product of two entries whose sum is
2020. now you know exactly what this
function is doing and make sure to
completely explicitly write out what
your variables are make those variable
names meaningful
this might still take you a little while
to go through and understand but at
least you have a better and shorter time
of trying to figure out what that means
if you see here this is something called
german naming
so who here has heard of chris dunn
raise your hand
no
okay neither have i but he wrote about
something and he wrote about something
that i thought you know i was already
doing i just didn't think anyone else
did it but every time i did write
variable names i would always be
explicit and my teammates would always
make fun of me and say jesus adrian why
is this so explicit i'm like but you
understand it right and that's the whole
point and so this person chris dunn he
wrote about something called the german
naming convention which is actually a
teammate that he had who was german and
who wrote their variable names super
super explicit so anyone that's learned
the german language right sometimes you
can get very very precise when you
combine words
to the dismay of my german husband i'm
going to try so what was the 1999 german
word of the year
it means beef labeling regulation and
delegation of supervision law
in german because they can be explicit
and connect things it's
etiquette runs
off
that's going to be on the internet
forever i'm sorry
but as you can see german naming
convention is great not just for our
code but for any code that's actually in
our tutorials if you use any code
samples in anything that you are
teaching any type of learning resource
or documentation be explicit in those
code samples too not only does it make
learning much more simple and easy to
understand you take away that cognitive
load for people who are trying to learn
what it is you are trying to teach so
german naming convention for the win you
want people to know that they understood
that is your goal
next tell me what i need
and
at the beginning of every single
tutorial there are things that you
should tell somebody so that they can
make a decision on whether or not
they're going to use your tutorial but
if you have these things the more likely
it is that you're going to have a
valuable tutorial so what should be part
of it tell me what background knowledge
will be helpful before starting this
tutorial if this is something super
intermediate if this is something that
you need two or three years of
programming experience on let me know
that tell me what i need to know rather
than having me read all the way through
and go oh wait there's still some other
background dependencies that i still
need to learn before i even understand
this thing tell me what those
prerequisites are
tell me what dependencies do i need to
download you'd be surprised as to how
many people write a tutorial and don't
tell me what i need they just go through
those steps and then just like in that
tutorial or they're like oh yeah by the
way we're using java seven not eight
they tell you halfway through and so
that's super super frustrating to get
halfway through a tutorial and then have
to wait because you have to download
some dependencies that you didn't know
that you needed so tell me what those
dependencies are and tell me them right
away
tell me can i complete this on a free
tier again with so many pieces moving to
the cloud with so many accounts that we
have to create with all of these
different services that we have to keep
track of let me know if this can be done
on a free tier or if i need a credit
card because sometimes that's going to
sway my decision and sometimes it's
going to tell me this is probably
something i don't want
so tell me potential costs of every
single partici uh learning resource that
i create tell me if there are some steps
that need to be completed before i start
sometimes before in the days of babel we
needed to transpile things and then we
can move on with our lives tell me those
kinds of steps tell me things that need
to be done beforehand tell me the
preconditions that are needed as part of
this tutorial and finally tell me an
estimate of how long this should take
we're all busy people every one of us
has a life every one of us likes to
get into the groove or zone of whenever
we want to learn things maybe it's
during work maybe it's during the
weekend maybe it's the 30 minutes that i
have free on wednesday after i make my
coffee i don't know but whatever your
schedule is if you tell people how long
approximately this thing should take
then people can estimate better when
they can fully focus on the tutorial
that they're about to follow from you
and the more likely they'll be able to
finish it and follow through so tell me
what i want what i really really want
and i could not find the spice girl's
for this i'm so upset so it's broken
the pattern but just imagine what's
there right it's like
right
so tell me what i need tell me what i
need tell me what i want
next unclear part is random screenshot
whodis
so here's a really nice looking
screenshot
but out of context it could be really
really useful or it could be completely
useless
what makes it useless
if the screenshot you have doesn't
support what you're trying to explain
don't put it in there
if it's paired with the incorrect step
make sure it's paired with the right
step
if it shows a different result than the
one that you're describing or worse it's
outdated or the ui looks different don't
use that screenshot
and if you don't have any meaningful alt
alt text on it or you don't have the
details of what's important about the
image in there
fix that as well
so
only add screenshots if they add actual
additional clarity to your tutorials
do your due diligence try naming your
screenshots so that they match the step
number that you have and make sure to
actually go through it and see that the
ones that you are expecting or
describing actually follow what is
happening on your page and follow what
screenshot is actually showing at that
step
follow your own steps and recapture the
actual results if necessary i know when
we are writing all of these types of
tutorials or we do series and we get
into the zone and it's a lot of work to
create really really useful meaningful
tutorials like this but sometimes you at
least need to go through your own steps
at least once to make sure that the
ending result is what your potential
learners will be following and expecting
as well it's also a great way to catch
any mistakes
and finally at a minimum put all of the
relevant settings and the inputs the
buttons whatever it is that you're
trying to show
in your screenshot make sure you add
that into the alt text as well
so don't be someone who's a random
screenshot make sure you know what
screenshot is going to you
and those are the top five for what
makes a lot of these things unclear
the next part are all of the five things
that i have found that i myself have
done before that make it unhelpful and
so these are also things we should try
to look out for
so the first one is oh
you didn't know that
so every single person i know no matter
who it is devrel other devs
documentation engineers technical
writers
maybe not as many as now but what we do
is we always assume that our reader has
knowledge on the topic whether that's oh
this is geared towards developers so
they're going to know xyz or this is
going to be geared towards this audience
so i don't have to write about these
basic pieces of information
no assume your reader has no knowledge
on the topic when you start out creating
any type of learning resource in this
fashion you are more focused on what
needs to be put into that learning
resource assume they don't know what
those acronyms are explain it and link
to it the first time assume they don't
know what it means to
install an npm package go through or
link to some preset instructions to tell
them how to do it make sure to be overly
explicit make sure to have as much
information as possible so that even if
you yourself six months down the line
decide to go through your own tutorial
and you forget you help yourself in the
future so assume that your reader has no
knowledge on the topic explain yourself
please
next thing that i have found is that no
more 404s
so in your tutorials you'll have in this
tutorial you'll learn how to use this
fancy new technology
though through a variety of use cases
but if you don't already have a fancy
service account be sure to create one
following this tutorial detailed
instructions on setting up your account
can be found
here
so if you've ever gone through a
tutorial like this
as i have many a time i'm sure you end
up feeling like this
you're just like i'm not going to go
through this anymore nothing is working
things that i need to get through this
tutorial are not there and there's no
footnotes there's no alternative one
links to point to
make sure those links are fixed
especially if they go to a preset
list of instructions or they are
integral pieces or services that's part
of your account fix those links make
sure that they are working it's
something so simple but something that
we take for granted and overlook often
fix it fix it fix it fix it please fix
it
fix it
next thing that is super unhelpful is
something i like to call
jump to recipe sorry
so
who here likes to bake
anybody
okay if you cook
okay
baking's better
but if you've ever found
all of these recipes right you look for
a recipe and then you find one you're
like oh this one looks good and then you
know most of these people who write them
they're like here's my whole life story
and you know i just got engaged and i
was thinking about what could i make for
my new fiance
and here's some more really pretty
pictures of what you could be making but
let me not tell you what it is
there are tutorials that are like this
right they're either so long that you
kind of lose track when you yourself
follow it or you only need a portion of
it a piece of it but you can't find
where to go because it's so damn long
instead we should do something
like this person or like what most
people are now adopting and that's this
really important button here
called jump to recipe
where you can skip their life story and
you can go exactly to what you need tell
me the ingredients that you need tell me
the steps that i need to take so i can
stuff my face with this jacked up banana
bread right and in the same fashion we
want to do this with our tutorials
so not to choose my own horn i am
ex-mungodb but this is something that i
did for a lot of the tutorials i had
when they were really really long i
would add a very very simple quick jump
section it could be a table of contents
it could be any set of links where you
tell someone hey this is what i'm going
to talk about here's where you can go
directly to do it and by adding this you
cut down on so many wasted hours of
people trying to just scroll through
find what portion it is that they
actually need and try to get through and
you make it easier for both you and them
help me help you
okay get straight to what you need to do
and then uh something i like to call not
now jiffy and yes i pronounce it jiffy
jiffy
jiffy so
with the exception of this presentation
because this context is different i'm
talking about videos
or more likely blog posts and more
written formats
we always find these types of tutorials
i did it myself i was very much like
this where you know you start out your
tutorial and at the end you're like
woohoo you put a woohoo jiff in there
and you're like you did it ray we got to
the point and then you find another one
and you want to convey how you may be
feeling to the learner you're like yeah
i was like this too what does this mean
i don't know what this error means and
then as you start searching you find an
inside joke and you're like oh that's
hilarious i'm going to put that in there
because that's exactly how i feel while
going through this tutorial so you put
that in there as well and then you go oh
well i'm going to talk about https so
let's add this because this is going to
make a great banner right and then
you're like oh let me add this one
because this is exactly how i feel as
well and you want to pump up those
learners make sure they're motivated get
them through the rest of the tutorial
and then you find other ones and you're
like well i just have to add that one in
there because i love silicon valley and
this is just great and by the time you
get to the end if you make it to the end
you're just like
i did not understand anything that you
just said
i got your jokes i laughed at some of
them but i didn't get to do what i
wanted to do i didn't actually follow
through the tutorial that you intended
to teach me it was so cluttered and
every other paragraph was a gif or a
joke that i kind of got lost and lost my
train of thought
so
not to say that all of these pieces are
bad or that you can't have any of them
at all granted mine is full of them
again different context presentation but
i think that if you resort to just one
if you clean up the clutter it will be
way more impactful leave it towards the
end or leave it where it will matter or
take it out where you
really need focus on some of the steps
and you don't want to distract your
learner try to have less than more
and finally
it works on my machine how many of you
people still use this excuse
yeah i'm confident i'm like yeah
how many people hear this from other
people and you're like
yeah
same same right when it's us it's like
oh no i did my best but it's someone
else you're like come on
so
it works on my machine so there are
plenty of tutorials
learning resources documentation that
surprisingly are still like this so they
go sorry this tutorial only works with
windows
or this sample repo relies on version
3.2.6 and above
or the rest of this guide assumes you
have this sdk installed
for all of these pieces rather than just
taking the easy way out rather than just
notifying your potential learner that
this is what they have to be aware of
take those pieces and make it platform
agnostic make it easier for the learner
they're already having a hard time
because they are about to learn
something potentially new when you add
all of this what we like to call dev set
up frustration it really really
decreases the likelihood that they're
going to continue on with your tutorial
so use docker create a container image
if you can of whatever it is that you
are about to teach make a sandbox
environment for them make it super super
simple
if you have the ability to create a
template repo or a starter app i mean
how many people how how many lives has
create to react app saved
oh wow okay
no
not even just to start
who has used create react up raise your
hand there we go inflating the numbers
so the point is if you can create
something that someone can start off of
if you can remove the boundaries of
setting something up and configuring
something before they can even get to
the point of learning the thing that
they need to learn do that for them do
that for your learner make it so that
they go this is so easy this is the
reaction that you want whenever you
create a learning resource you want
someone to feel empowered you want
someone to feel like they can take on
another tutorial you want someone to
know that they can do it and it actually
speaks to both of you because if you can
make someone feel like this with your
learning resource that means you have
done a damn fine job of creating that
piece
[Applause]
so for the bad for all of the learning
resources that we've ever create and
will create for the rest of our lives
we need to do the bare minimum actually
we need to do the bare minimum to make
it not unclear and unusable but concise
and valuable so to recap
shaking my head i don't know spell out
the damn abbreviations say the darn
thing
just at least put it in the first
sentence the whole thing and then write
out what you're going to abbreviate with
and then you can abbreviate for the rest
of your tutorial
check your steps before you wreck
yourselves
please don't skip your steps don't go
halfway through and say oh by the way
you need this or you need that oh
there's this important piece of
information that you're missing make
sure you explicitly go through every
step and get the result that you want
and follow through your own steps to see
that you are getting that result that
you want
use german naming convention
please
first things first tell me what i want
what i really really want preconditions
prerequisites potential costs how much
time and the fifth one i'm already
forgetting but tell me everything that i
could possibly need to know about my
tutorial so that i am ready for it so i
can estimate when to do it and so that i
am ready to follow through it all the
way without any hiccups in between
make screenshots make sense pair them
with the right steps put alt text on all
of the images if a gif is better use a
gif and if they actually add clarity to
what you're trying to explain then add
them otherwise take them out
make sure everybody knows that do not
assume that people know knowledge on the
topic that you're about to teach
come from a standpoint of that they know
nothing and be able to write that and
infuse that in any learning resource
that you do
repair those links fix it fix it fix it
you don't want someone to go all the way
through and then get to a crucial point
and have a 404 and they're like
let's go let's get out of here
use the jump to recipe method add quick
jump links and get on with your day
help people by having them go to exactly
the point that they want and make your
own tutorials and learning resources way
easier to digest because it's broken
down into digestible chunks
and then have just a little jiffy for a
snack not to distract so again you can
add your humor in there you can infuse
it with the gif or two but make sure it
is not overwhelming make sure it is not
too distracting make sure you still get
your point across and you still teach
something in the thing that it is you're
trying to teach and then finally make
sure it works on all machines not just
your machine and if you have all of
these pieces i guarantee you that you'll
have concise and valuable learning
resources and you will have the best
pieces in every single learning resource
that you make
so
kazunum stephen jsconf budapest i'm
adrian berganza tucker i'm going to be a
cloud developer advocate at soon i'm
going to announce next week
but yeah thank you thank you so much i
hope this helps
[Applause]
you